[Music]
and tonight a violent and chaotic
situation in the Middle East continues
to get worse two Navy Seals are missing
tonight after taking part in What was a
critical mission to intercept a shipment
of Iranian missiles headed for Yemen Now
search and rescue operations are
underway in the Gulf of Aiden now
meanwhile Yemen's hoodi Rebels they
continue their attacks in the Red Sea
even striking an American cargo ship
yesterday with a ballistic missile and
now finally Biden is PL planning to
uh once again redesignate the hoodies as
a terrorist organization remember he
very generously removed the terror label
shortly after taking office even though
they regularly committed acts of
terrorism at the behest of Iran at least
Joe wasn't trying to give them billions
like he was doing for the Iranian
mullers this all comes as defense
secretary Lloyd Austin is out of the
hospital after nearly two weeks stay and
this that was not initially disclosed by
the way to anybody it was 8 Days Later
that Joe Biden found out he actually had
cancer or I'm sorry or actually had a
prostate problem anyway here was
reaction as former Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo we do wish him a speedy
recovery so we were told oh Great
Britain and Joe Biden they responded to
the hoodie Rebels we find out later that
at the most maybe five people were
killed now the hoodies are firing
ballistic missiles at American ships uh
and there's no response as per usual
you're
reaction yeah Sean this is this is a
problem that was a policy driven problem
the bid Administration got this wrong
from the outset uh you're right um they
we we designated the houthi a foreign
terrorist organization they now have had
to acknowledge that whoops these guys
are really terrorists they were firing
missiles into Saudi Arabia I remember
speaker Pelosi screaming at all of us
because they wanted to try and get food
and Aid in there when in fact what we
needed to do was inflict a real cost on
these very same houthis that are now
disrupting sea Lanes going to make a
food prices for Americans more expensive
and you you you got it right as well
they they fundamentally misunderstand
this threat whether it's whether it's
the bid administration's efforts to
restrain Israel when they need to
destroy Hamas or the administration's
effort to uh just you know pin prick
Iran when they're threatening the lives
of Americans 125 plus attacks on
American interests in the Middle East
this is unacceptable we can't let this
happen and you I'm praying for those two
Navy Seals but this is precisely the
kind of thing that happens Sean when
America isn't strong and doesn't deter
our adversaries I I at this point I just
think all the world sees is a
cognitively impaired weak and feral
president and and I've got to imagine
based on the fact that Joe never
responds seemingly to any incident that
they they think they have free reign I
have no doubt this year while Joe is
president that in fact the reunification
of Taiwan with China is going to occur
meaning they're going to try and take
over an independent state uh do you
disagree with me I hope I'm wrong
wrong yeah I I hope you're wrong too I
don't know that they'll do it this year
but your core point which is that these
are adversaries see this moment right
they can see that President Biden is not
up to the task of Defending American
interest they whether it was what
happened in Afghanistan where had 13
Americans killed or The Invasion by
Vladimir Putin into Europe these are the
kind of things that happen when America
isn't unwatch doing the basic task of
convincing our allies to defend
themselves and supporting them when they
do uh whe whether whether ching will
actually move on Taiwan in the next 10
or 12 months make no mistake about it
they know that President Biden's got
another year he may only have that other
that one more year and they're going to
do everything they can to seize the
leverage and the moment to make this
next administration's job even that much
more difficult I I honestly you know
I've never been this concerned about the
economy about uh what's happening in the
country to American citizens and I've
never been this concerned about what's
going on abroad and if the adults like
yourself but not put in charge soon you
know I fear the very worst in you know a
lot of parts of the world we're now
hearing about Putin's uh potential to go
after NATO Nations after he's done with
Ukraine your thoughts on
that yeah I've said since the beginning
Putin's intentions were deeper than just
ke just Ukraine he he had he had bigger
Ambitions the ukrainians were able to
stop him with a lot of American help so
good on us for that I know the bad guys
are moving around pretty freely we saw
chairman Kim make an announcement said
he's no longer interested in unifying
with South Korea dangerous times Sean
yeah very dangerous we need you back in
charge I know you've sacrificed a lot of
your life serving your country we could
use your back in charge again thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else